Hello.
Today is October 31st in the year
2024.
I'm Karen Herman, and I have the
pleasure of conducting an interview with Larry
Rosen for the Free Stories Digital Archives
Foundation.
So welcome, Larry.
Thank you so much for joining us
today.
Thank you for inviting me.
Okay.
So we're going to start right from
the beginning.
When and where were you born?
Say that again.
I didn't hear your question.
I'm sorry.
Oh, no.
No.
It's okay.
When and where were you born?
When and where was I born?
Yes, I was born in New York
City.
Um, the when was a long time
ago.
June 29th, 1945.
Okay.
Um.
And talk a little bit.
What was your childhood like?
What kind of kid were you?
I'm hard of hearing.
So you're going to have to try
to enunciate your questions a little more
carefully.
Understood.
What kind of kid were you growing
up?
What kind of kid was I?
Uh, well, it depends on who you
ask, I guess.
Um, my parents would probably say I
was a little bit of a trouble,
but actually, I was a pretty good
kid.
I went to school, I read, I
learned a lot.
I did well in school.
I did well in my life.
And, uh, I guess I was a
normal, ordinary, well brought up, happy young
boy.
And talk about your education.
Where did you go to college?
Well, let me let me backtrack a
little bit.
I was born in New York.
I was raised in Colorado.
My parents moved to Colorado because my
father had a lung disease and he
needed to treat it.
And so we moved there.
And I grew up in Denver or
the outskirts of Denver, in a city
called Thornton.
I went to, uh, to uh, uh,
uh, preschool and, uh, high school and
so on in, in that area, when
it got time to apply to colleges,
I applied to a variety of them,
and I was admitted to Dartmouth College
in Hanover, New Hampshire, and I went
to college there, which was the best,
the luckiest opportunity I think I ever
had.
What did you study.
In college, I studied math and English.
I ended up with English mostly.
Turned out math was not exactly my
best forte.
Um, and mostly because Dartmouth was the
kind of college it was.
They had just invented timesharing.
I studied computer science before there was
a computer science department.
Uh, I became a devotee of that.
I played with the computers that they
made available to all of us.
They had computers in the student rooms.
Student.
Um, not dormitories, but the the student
buildings.
And I went and I studied and
I learned basic, which was the language
invented at Dartmouth specifically for time sharing.
And I became one of the devotees
of that language.
I wrote programs for it.
I helped to design and implement certain,
uh, training manuals for myself and other
students.
And I became a, uh, an expert
in computer science, such as there were
experts in those days, in addition to,
uh, a normal education in a liberal
arts institution.
And the good combination, liberal arts and
computer science is a combination I would
recommend to people.
They should be able to talk about
something other than how to program, and
I learned how to do many other
things besides programming.
What did you want to do with
that when you graduated?
I wasn't sure, but I applied to
graduate school and was admitted to University
of North Carolina at Chapel Hill and
studied computer science.
I was in their computer science department.
It was a very interesting, not very
happy part of my life.
I was not happy being isolated in
North Carolina.
I found the school and the department
too conservative for my tastes, and so
I lasted there a few years and
then went off to work in New
York City as a programmer.
What kind of things were you programming?
The first program I remember working on
was kind of weird.
It was, um, it was a program
to try to determine what people's sign
was in their, uh, when they were
born and what kinds of influences the
planets were having on them.
And I wrote those programs and didn't
believe a word of it, but I
wrote and they asked me to develop
software for that, and I did that
until I got a what I would
call a real job at RCA, then
in new Jersey, that had a computer
business that they were running.
They were going to be the IBM
of, I guess, of the future.
Um, that lasted for a few years.
I was involved in helping them to
develop the operating system software for their
computers, uh, particularly the database aspects of
their software.
And it was quite a learning experience
as well as gratifying in terms of
developing stuff that was real software as
opposed to, uh, what's your sign and
what's your what planets you were born
under.
But, um, driving home one day on
a weekend, I guess it was on
a Friday.
I was listening to NBC news on
the radio, and there was an announcement
that RCA decided to go out of
the computer business, which left me kind
of perplexed as to what to do
next.
But it turns out that because I
was in their development department and involved
very deeply in the development of their
database and their operating system, I was
part of the departments that were kept
on, and we were kept on in
order to be sold.
And so I proceeded to start to
look for jobs, even though I continued
to draw salary and work for RCA
Until I ended up with a job
in California, and it was a company
called Memorex.
They may.
For all I know, they're still around.
I don't know for sure.
And they recruited me and put my
furniture on a truck and put my
dogs in and their puppies in my
car.
And we drove to California and I
showed up for work.
And the day I showed up, they
said, oh, by the way, we've decided
we're going to cut back.
And so your job is no longer.
So there I was, sitting in a
motel room with my dog, my furniture
on a truck, and Wondering what I
was going to do.
It turns out I got another temporary
job, which was gross programming, sitting in
an office with three other programmers, writing
software that I didn't believe in, and
I proceeded to earn a salary and
live in my motel room until I
got settled.
And, um, I ended up finding a
job at a company called Rome r
o m.
You may have heard of them.
They were in the telephone systems business,
and, um, they hired me to help
them develop a program, develop their software,
and develop, um, their applications.
that lasted for about nine years.
When did you start?
What year did you start?
Oh my goodness.
Uh, I.
That's a good question I don't remember.
Okay.
It was in the early '80s, I
think.
Yeah.
It looks it looks like maybe '82.
That sounds like I'm glad you're better
at my, uh, resume than I am,
but I ended up working for them.
They were known as, quote, a great
place to work in the Bay area.
And it was true.
They had all sorts of facilities for
employees to participate to, to do sports,
to do that a swimming pool they
had.
Training opportunities.
I really enjoyed them.
They were a good company and I
learned a lot.
And I became responsible for some of
their database software and became experienced in
that field.
And, um, that worked very well until
they decided that they were going to
sell to IBM, which at the time
was the first company.
We were the first company that IBM
ever bought.
So all of a sudden I found
myself, uh, a member of a company
that had a reputation for being rather
big, rather, um, managerial and its style
and somewhat different.
I was able to stay at Rome
slash IBM during a time when they
were still giving sabbaticals to their employees.
So if you work for six or
more years, you had an opportunity to
take a lengthy sabbatical, which I did,
and I went to Europe and I
enjoyed myself, and I learned a bunch
of things and did a bunch of
things to become, I guess, better trained,
better educated.
And, um, IBM was a strange place
to work.
It was a good place in that
they did.
They treated their employees well.
They treated us well.
They, uh, they wanted to make a
success out of the telecommunications business.
And it turns out they didn't know
squat about telecommunications.
And so they ended up selling us
as a business to Siemens.
And I ended up working at Siemens.
Same office, same complex, same co-workers, working
on similar businesses.
But the the company name changed on
the signs outside on the street.
It was um, also an interesting experience.
Uh, German industry is different from IBM.
It's quite a bureaucratic in some sense.
They're the head of there who they
assigned to be in charge of us
was one of those, I will tell
you what to do kind of people.
And we did and we developed database
software and so on.
But I grew tired of that.
I just couldn't find a comfortable personal
situation working for a German company to
develop software that I don't think they
knew much about what they were doing.
In point of fact, several years after
I left there, they ended up doing
other things.
But in any event, I went to
Stanford University.
I hope I'm doing this in the
right sequence and became responsible for a
database package called Spires, which was a
really innovative database system in that individual
departments, individuals in the business, in the
Stanford business, would be able to develop
their own database applications.
So I was responsible for training them
for developing their applications, for helping them
to take advantage of the database software
that was developed there.
And it was really quite an opportunity.
First of all, to become familiar with
many aspects of the university.
I remember writing applications of, for one
department or another that helped them to
do what their function was in the
university, and I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed meeting them.
I enjoyed writing applications.
I built a small staff of people
who worked on that.
Eventually I became head of the, uh,
sort of, uh.
Development department in the Stanford Computer Center
that hired out to other departments to
help them to develop applications.
And so as a result, I became
even more familiar with the university, even
more familiar with the applications of helping
students educate themselves.
I did a lot of teaching.
I taught a lot of computer programming
classes.
I developed a software department that that
had other people that worked on developing
software training for the university, and it
was rewarding.
I worked there, I think 11 years.
It was it was very good.
But I became aware of the fact
that if you're at a university and
you're not on the faculty, you're not
anything.
It isn't quite that you're not anything.
It's just that you're you're not going
to go very far.
You're not going to become, uh, whatever,
uh, main faculty member is in the
university.
So I decided to look around for
other opportunities.
And that was when I decided that
it was time to take advantage of
another, uh, goal that I had had
for many years, which was to study
law to try to become a lawyer.
And they were very supportive.
They allowed me to do that.
Um, in part, they helped pay for
it.
It was it was a great opportunity.
I got admitted to a great law
department at Santa Clara University.
They had a night program, so I
was able to do my work at
Stanford during the day and study law
at nights and weekends.
And whenever I was alone in the
car driving off to see my parents
or whatever I was doing.
So four years later, I graduated from
law school with a law degree, and
by that time, I was not the
sort of person that would be hired
in a big law firm to, you
know, work his way up to senior
partner.
There were others I went to school
with who did, but they were a
little younger and a little bit more
adventurous, perhaps, than I was.
And some of them were quite successful.
And I passed the bar right away.
So I became a lawyer, and I
went to work for a law firm
that turned out to be not so
much fun, and I went off and
decided to be a lawyer on my
own to to be by myself an
attorney, helping with computer programming and with
computer software and to to to continue
combining my computer science degrees with my
law degree.
And I figured I could do that
more effectively than working for, um, a
law firm that really had no concept
of what computer software was about.
And.
Yeah.
Was that your intent?
It wasn't a rewarding.
Was that your pardon?
Was that your intent when you got
the law degree to to be able
to combine that with the computer technology?
Was that.
Absolutely.
There.
I love computers, I love doing computers.
I love I met many people in
the Bay area who were involved in
computers.
I made many friends, uh, discovered various
things that were going on.
One of the friends that I met
was a software developer who at the
time worked for Xerox and, uh, developed
Small talk, which was a computer programming
language.
And he was a good friend of
mine.
And we worked and we talked and
he said, you know, I'm, I'm working
with this organization on the East Coast
called the Open Source Initiative.
And he says, would.
You like to meet them?
Why not?
And I did meet them, and I
found them very interesting and very challenging.
And I found that their objective of
providing free software, I don't want to
use the word free, but let's call
it open source software.
Uh, was a good idea.
It sort of tied in many ways
to what I was doing at a
university, where the objective was not to
make money.
Uh, the department I was in charge
of was not a profit center.
It was, um, had to survive, but
it would its its objective was to
do good things for the university and
for the faculty and so on, and
ozone seem to have some of the
same objectives.
And I began to meet with them,
and I began to meet their people.
And I became enamored of their organization.
And they said, well, look, you have
a college background in computers and you
have a college background in law, and
that's a good combination for doing licensing
kinds of things.
That open source initiative.
Would you like to come and join
us?
Now, of course, I had a practice.
I was working with various companies and
doing various legal things.
And, you know, whatever walked in the
door became a client.
But I was also very interested in
that combination.
I liked writing.
I like teaching.
I like working with software.
And this seemed like an interesting combination.
And it was.
So this was about 1997.
Is that about the year?
Yeah.
Somewhere around in that time.
When was the first time that you
heard about open source?
Was it through OSI or did you
know about open source even earlier than
that?
Well, my friend had told me a
bunch about open source and what it
was.
He had formed a company that developed
software that was released under a commercial
first, then open source software license, and
he taught me about how he did
that.
And I watched all the software that
he wrote and the people that he
worked with.
And of course, I met many people
in the community.
Silicon Valley was a dynamic, uh, environment
at that time, and I met many
people who were supportive and who understood
open source and, you know, ended up
meeting people who were mostly on the
East Coast.
But, you know, we talked and, um,
I discovered that they had good objectives.
They wanted to develop open source software
that people could use that was not
designed to make money.
That was, um, unusual for me.
It was not exactly something I could
relate to.
Making money is not a foreign thing
for me.
I had to pay my mortgage and
I, you know, I had to live.
And, um, I found that the people
that were in the open source community
were fascinating.
They were all very different.
They were all politically astute.
Among the things that I found was
that they were, for the most part,
gun nuts.
Uh, Second Amendment was more important than
the First Amendment to them, which was
a little bit unusual for me.
I've never used a gun in my
life and have no intention of it.
In fact, one of the people that
I met through that organization had resigned
from the OSI board because he thought
they were threatening him with guns.
I don't want to mention names because
it's someone you've already interviewed, but, um,
there was a kind of a tension
in the organization, and I tried to
work to, to resolve the tension, to
get them to work together, to get
them to forgive each other for whatever
slights they had read.
And, uh, I did a certain amount
of that successfully and a certain amount,
not because, you know, working with Richard
Stallman is not the easiest thing in
the world.
Um, and several others on that board.
Can you talk a little bit about
Richard Stallman or your relationship with him?
I met him through ISI.
He was not on the OSI board,
but he was, of course, a very
powerful figure in the open source community.
He had developed the GPL license, which
I read and appreciated.
And I met his legal advisor, who
was a professor at Columbia University, and
was able to talk to him and
to share a little bit about what
open source and free software was all
about.
In fact, I remember one time he
came to California and we sat in
a restaurant, the two of us, and
talked about open source and free software.
And I quite frankly, I found him
to be a rather strange personality, but.
We're all strange.
We all had our quirks and our
imbalances.
And, um, I just was able to
share his desire for free software.
Um, but I didn't like his license.
I found there were deficiencies in the
license.
And the law professor from Columbia that
had served as his, as Richard's law
advisor was largely a jerk.
And and he kept insisting on certain
aspects of the the legal basis for
law in the open source community that
I found strange and unsupportable.
And he was just sort of like
a mean person.
Anyway, so he and I did not
get along very well, and he used
to call me names and I used
to laugh at him.
Um, but in terms of the of
the general goals and objectives of open
source, even though Richard was definitely not
a part of OSI, refused.
OSI, quite frankly, didn't want to be
a part of OSI, thought that their
philosophy was too liberal, too open, and
that there were certain kinds of interactions
that Ozai sought out with commercial companies
that Richard Stallman and the Free Software
Foundation didn't like, didn't share.
And so even though I was able
to talk to them and become friendly
with them, it was clear that Ozai
was something different.
Ozai was a commercially friendly, open source
organization, and that they wanted to develop
licenses and support structures that would help
commercial companies build software that was open
source.
This was something that was foreign to
Richard Stallman.
He cared not at all about the
commercial businesses.
He cared not at all about trying
to make life easier for them.
And I found that, um.
I don't know, because perhaps I'm more
liberal than socialist at the time.
I felt that he was going too
far.
That in particular, his lawyer was going
too far and saying things like, open
source licenses are not contracts, they're just
copyrights.
And I said, it's not how I
learned it.
That's not what I understood.
And I began to work with companies
through OSI to help them to develop
their own licenses.
I would have companies that would, and
I'm not going to mention specific companies.
I don't think that would be appropriate.
But companies that said, uh, we want
to develop licenses that are different from
OCI, uh, different from Free Software Foundation,
that that were friendlier to open source
without being, um, restrictive in the kinds
of licensing and development activities that they
would support.
And so my efforts were on the
outside of Free Software Foundation, not the
inside of Free Software Foundation.
They were on the inside of OSI
trying to Ignore their gun rhetoric and
their second amendment bullshit.
And sorry, a little bit of politics
is allowed, I presume on this thing,
and to work to have them work
with developers and with software companies and
with, uh, um, application, uh, opportunities that
were not quite free.
Software Foundation GPL activities.
And while I was still friendly with
the Free Software Foundation and friendly with
the people, I tried not to be
too biased or too bigoted about certain
things.
Um, they they did not support what
I did.
They did not like the fact that
I was being supportive of what was
the open source definition that you're familiar
with, that they had a different philosophy,
and I shared their philosophy more than
I shared the Free Software Foundation.
So I was kind of in a,
in a two worlds situation trying to
balance, excuse me, trying to balance my
social work for software companies while also
developing my social work for developers so
that developers could take advantage of the
opportunities of free software.
Little coffee always helps.
So I worked with them for several
years and developed licenses for the companies
that supported OSI, and also developed a
license for OSI itself that would make
the OSI board of directors comfortable with
a license that that was phrased differently
from the GPL.
Yeah.
How is it different?
The GPL is a strong copyright oriented
license that wanted very much to prevent
companies from developing software that could compete
with GPL software.
So one of the facets of their
license, which quite frankly, I didn't read
the same way, but they had this
Columbia professor who had his own attitude
that it was a license that they
felt did not allow commercial.
Successfully commercial development that companies could not
develop software that sold, that made money.
That competed with GPL software.
That absence of competition bothered me.
I didn't understand why they had to
restrict companies from developing commercially successful software.
That it was not fair to programmers
who needed to make a living.
And so I would develop licenses that
were supportive in some sense of commercial
development.
Examples of in today's world are like
the Mozilla license and.
And licenses that authorized the development of
derivative works that were competitive with open
source.
And not everyone agreed with that, but
not everyone disagreed with that.
So Osai was more supportive of the
development of derivative works that were competitive
with open source, with Free Software Foundation
and Free Software Foundation to this day
has more of a let's control it.
Let's prevent the development of derivative works
that can compete with us because they'll
make money and we won't.
They'll have successes that we want.
And it's just they were different.
It wasn't that there was a war
going on.
It's just that they had a different
basis for understanding what what open source
software was all about.
I thought open source was more for
the engineer to develop software, to make
it free, to have it be available,
and to form companies that would sell
and make a profit and fund They're
engineers.
And whereas to this day there are
various parts of the Free Software Foundation
that believe that that's not what it's
about, that it's about giving software, creating
software that is always free, even when
a derivative work is created.
And I, I couldn't I couldn't buy
that.
I just didn't think that it was
fair to engineers.
You know, I'm one of many and
not everyone agreed with me.
And not everyone agrees with me today.
Um, there are still difficult The differences.
And in fact, one of the reasons
I left OSI was because they were
too strong in that way.
They were.
Unwilling to find a compromise to the
people that they threatened with their guns,
or that they threatened with their software
development philosophies, and that there were people
in the free software community, that and
the open source software community that didn't
want to play that restrictive game.
And I didn't either.
So I ultimately left.
And what I did was I wrote
a book.
Talk about that.
That was a it was a 2020
and 22,004.
You wrote this book?
Yes.
Um, I wanted to say what I
thought were the core issues of copyright
law and contract law with respect to
software and with respect to open source,
that by describing the differences between the
various kinds of licenses, I would be
able to explain why someone might choose
one license over another, why they might
choose my license, for example, which allowed
derivative works under certain circumstances, as opposed
to the Free Software Foundation GPL, which
claimed it wasn't even a contract, that
it was just copyright.
And we don't want we don't want
derivative works.
So I decided to write a book
that explained the law.
That was more a function of what
the law would say than what these
politically directed organizations would say.
And that was not always popular.
So there were a couple of people
on the open source board who found
that Unattractive and I didn't need them
and they didn't need me, so I.
So I left Ozzie and tried to
figure out how to reintegrate Ozzie into
the software community.
I worked with various people about, you
know, what can we do to reorganize
Ozzie, to reorganize Free Software Foundation?
What can we do to keep them
from being antagonistic to each other?
And it turns out that that was
not a very popular motive, that O.s.i
was successful and the Free Software Foundation
was Successful, and there wasn't a great
deal of interest in trying to merge
them or combine them, or try to
develop a consistent philosophy that would result
in open source software that allowed derivative
works without being too competitive.
It just it was not a possibility.
It just Ozzie was not all in
favor of it.
And some were free software.
People were not all in favor of
it, but some were.
And I was there in the middle.
You know who's Larry Rosen?
What in the world does he have
to say with all of this?
He's just a he's just a programmer
who became a lawyer.
And, um, so I left Ozzie and
I became a member of Apache.
Which had a different philosophy, a very
open philosophy, a very a philosophy where
software could be developed into derivative works.
And they had companies like IBM and
even Google to some degree, supporting them
in the development of their open source
model.
And I felt very good about that.
And I eventually got elected to the
board of OSA, of of Apache in
support of the kinds of things that
I described to you a few minutes
ago.
And that is, there were certain things,
certain aspects of OSI, of I'm sorry,
of Apache that really rankled on me.
Still do.
I think they have a kind of
a religious attitude toward software, toward their
development model.
I think they wake up every morning
and say religious prayers to the Apache
model, and I'm not religious, so I
found that uncomfortable.
And I said to them, and I
tried from my position on the board
to influence other members of the board
and members of the Apache Foundation.
Can we find some way to combine
our forces with the Free Software Foundation?
For example, if we're going to develop
a competitive product to Microsoft Word and
they're developing a competitive product of Microsoft
Word.
Two competitors to Microsoft Word doesn't make
sense.
It just you're wasting software effort.
You're developing software that you can't use
their software and they won't use your
software.
So we got two teams, each of
whom wakes up in the morning and
makes their prayers to whatever God of
open source they have and and won't
work together.
Won't.
Won't help.
Open source.
So I ended up leaving the Apache
board.
I just I couldn't I couldn't support
the separateness of these two organizations where
the people in the Apache Foundation would
not accept any software licensed under the
GPL, and the Free Software Foundation would
not accept software developed under the Apache
license.
So Y2Y.
What is it that we can't find?
Some sort of a basis for cooperation.
I couldn't do it.
They never did.
They still wake every morning with their
prayers and still develop software in their
own way.
And I just.
It just didn't make sense to me.
I continued, obviously, to work with companies.
I had clients that wanted one license
or another, and I found that OSI,
the Free Software Foundation, worked very hard
to develop GPL.
Number two, the successor license to the
GPL.
And I worked on their committee and
I helped as much as I could
there.
And meanwhile, OSI started accepting licenses from
everyone who wanted to write a license.
People who weren't lawyers.
People who were lawyers.
People who were lawyers and didn't know
the law.
Um, and I just they kept saying,
well, we don't want your license, so
we'll go with others.
And some are better than others.
And it's true, every every lawyer is
like me and has an ego and
loves the words that we develop in
our licenses.
And once our license to be the,
you know, the one that God speaks.
But after a while, Ozzy had too
many licenses.
They still have too many licenses.
They've become a little bit better at
it.
They now say you have to get
an approval by a lawyer before you
can submit a license for Ozzy approval,
but there's still 100 licenses.
And, you know, a software company wants
to develop software.
Well, what license do they use?
Well, you know, from my perspective, they
should use my license.
It's the best one ever written.
It's law.
It's language is perfectly clear.
That isn't that isn't their attitude, that
isn't the way they deal with it.
And they're free.
I mean, I like my licenses.
They like their licenses.
They're allowed.
Lawyers have different opinions.
We even have lawyers on the Supreme
Court that have opinions.
Um.
But but I found it.
I just I couldn't keep doing it.
I just couldn't help one versus the
other.
When they refuse to work together, when
when the objectives of these two organizations
became something other than great software.
That's what the objective is here.
Software that maybe everyone can use, maybe
more people can use.
Maybe there are different versions of software
that have features or functions that are
better than others.
And if it's the issue of cooperation
that I just couldn't I couldn't deal
with it.
I just I said, I'm too old.
I'm too tired of doing this kind
of getting people to be friendly to
each other, getting people to be not
afraid that they're going to be shot
by gun nuts.
I just, Uh, it it didn't make
me happy anymore, and I didn't need
to do it.
I think that open source software is
still.
A great idea, a great solution to
the problem of a commercial lock away
to the problem of private.
Um, advantage for commercial companies over the
software engineers who are trying to do
good stuff.
I'm all in favor of that.
I like GPL people.
I like Apache People.
I like both organizations, not just those
organizations, but there are others, you know,
Mozilla and others that are have their
own philosophies.
I like them all because the fundamental
objective that they have is good software
that's open and free.
But not entirely.
And and as such, it just it
rankled me.
It got me feeling like I was.
Hurting the software community.
I was not helping people anymore.
It's okay.
I don't have to.
They don't need me.
Um.
You know, I even had some differences
over the open source definition.
Which was what?
Too long?
Too many clauses.
What I ended up doing is writing
my book, in which I summarize the
open source definition in five clauses, rather
than ten clauses.
But, you know, I'm not going to
change their ways.
I'm not going to cause them to
erase five of their clauses or combine
them in some way.
Those people are friends of mine, I
like them, I know their hearts are
in the right place, and I'm not
the only writer in the world.
So yes.
Oh, so did the book when when
the book came out, did people, you
know, have very, um, opinion, opinions of
it strongly?
Actually, yes.
I was quite surprised.
I was very pleased that Larry Lessig,
professor of law now at Harvard, was
quite generous in his comments about it,
about what I said and how I
said it.
There are still people who use it,
although it's no longer in print, and
it talks about licenses that have been
surpassed and replaced.
Um, I've been asked to come up
with a new version of the book
and no, not needed.
Um, but yes, it was successful.
I think it did stimulate people to
think about what open source licenses are.
It did stimulate people to write their
own licenses for whatever their reasons would
be.
But, um, so I think it was
a success.
You know, that's life.
Okay.
Um, how are you doing?
Do you need to take a break
or anything or.
Ask your question again.
Oh, I just asked you if you
needed to take a break.
Or are you?
I have nothing more to add.
All right.
So I think I've expressed myself in
ways that are.
Perhaps too candid.
Um, I've not been a shy person
most of my life.
I do have opinions about things.
Yeah, so does everyone.
And, um, I'm willing to stand by
them until someone proves to me that,
uh, they're the wrong opinions.
Yeah.
So?
So were you involved in any litigation
on these?
Oh, yeah.
Over the years.
I mean, I've been an attorney for
30 years now, and I've represented many
companies, including some of the larger ones,
some of the smaller ones, some of
the successful ones, some of the failures.
I've represented individual programmers.
I've represented companies that have done shit
things to their programmers, and companies that
have done good things to their programmers.
Um, yeah, I've had a success, what
I consider to be a successful legal
career.
I, uh, there were many opportunities during
that career for me to sign on
to other Law firms or other companies,
and it just never worked out.
It never felt right.
And so I've not become rich and
I struggle to pay my mortgage every
month.
And, you know, the but I have
a nice place to live.
I live on 158 acre ranch.
Um, I'm now involved.
Although I don't do anything with it,
I let it do its thing in
the cannabis industry in Mendocino County.
I don't use it, but, you know,
it's good stuff.
So yes, I'm satisfied with my life,
with what I've done with the companies
I've helped and the company and the
individuals and programmers I've helped.
I have no regrets.
Going to law school was a good
decision.
I could probably have made more money
doing software.
Writing software, managing software companies and so
on.
But money isn't everything.
Yeah.
How do you how do you think
the open source has changed since you
got into it?
I think it's been a success.
An enormous.
Excuse me?
An enormous success.
That's something on which I take great
pride, because I think that I have
contributed in many ways to the success
of open source.
I'm watching now as people are arguing
about artificial intelligence, and somehow or another
it's going to be the the replacement
for open source in some way.
And maybe it will, I don't know,
I it's beyond me.
It's not my field.
Um, but I think open source has
been an enormous, enormous success.
It's as successful in Europe.
It's successful in Asia, in Africa, in
the United States.
It's had this flurry of licenses that
have been developed by people who have
tried to improve it over the years
and add features and add opportunities and
make life better for engineers.
I think that's a great success and
I suppose.
Um, I want to accept a some
credit for that.
I want to accept some credit for
having made good friends, for having not
made as many enemies as I've made
friends.
I think open source is here for
good for forever.
It's there's no way of undoing it.
There's no reason to undo it.
There are enough people who are in
favor of it who like it to
benefit from it, that I'm proud.
I sit back in my chair with
pride at having helped to convert to
something that is new and good and
beneficial.
It's got it's, you know, the people
who make their prayers every morning.
Uh, it's it's like any human activity.
And I'm pleased with the way it's
developed.
I was reading some blurb in Google
News about how the former president of
Microsoft used to say that open source
was communistic and was going to destroy
the software industry.
And so he was wrong.
He was wrong.
And I'm proud of that.
I'm proud that I was able to
to have some influence over that.
Not total.
Maybe not even permanent, but open source
is here for good.
It's here.
What about in other fields?
Have you seen it being adopted in
other fields and other technologies.
Uh, the one that I have seen
that I really appreciate is the scientific
community.
I in my spare time, when I'm
not thinking about open source law, I'm
thinking about physics.
And I read a lot of things
in the physics journals and and so
on.
And I'm noticing that more and more
of them are adopting open source principles
that when a scientist publishes his publication,
ought not to be, uh, secret, ought
not to be under a license that
prevents the sharing of that information.
And I'm most pleased that the scientific
community has accepted open source philosophy with
respect to their own studies, their own
writings, their own developments.
That it's not a question of keeping
it secret so that they can make
a profit.
I don't care if they earn their
Nobel Prizes and get their private benefits
from, you know, awards and so on.
So long as the, the, the, the
thought processes that go into the creation
of works that humans can use.
Is free is available.
So in terms of to answer your
question, I, I think that's the greatest
opportunity that's happened.
Science has become freer.
Um.
I think that's a benefit.
Yeah, that's a great insight too.
It really is.
Anything else before we before we conclude,
is there anything else you'd like to
to talk about a little bit about
your personal life and or, you know,
what's you're up to now?
Well, like I said, what I'm up
to now is, um, I do a
lot of reading.
I follow what's going on in the
open source community.
I'm fascinated.
I occasionally respond, but mostly I'm interested
in science.
Mostly I'm interested in physics, and I
think if I had a life to
live over again, I'd be an astronomer
or a cosmologist because.
There's bigger things in software.
And because it's it's enlightening and challenging.
I watch these programs on Nova and
other television programs about astronomy and science,
and I say, so now I understand
that a billion years from now, we
won't be here.
A billion years from now, there'll be
something else.
God knows what.
But that's part of the universe.
That's the way the universe works.
That my.
I think about the fact that when
Albert Einstein reached the end of his
life, he said, don't try to save
me.
Don't try to put, you know, medicines
in me that are going to cure
me of whatever in the world he
had.
He said, it's time.
And so when I study science and
when I studied physics and when I
study cosmology, and I see.
Uh, the future.
I'm just thrilled.
I'm just delighted that I'm able to
last long enough to see.
To see the planets.
To see the comets.
To see the stars explode and the
galaxies move about.
What an opportunity.
And and it's part of, you know,
it's just a growth for me of
the opportunity with open source.
Because I didn't create open source.
I didn't I didn't make it happen.
It happened.
But I was there.
And I'm here now.
And somehow or another life in the
universe are going to go on.
And I'm just thrilled with that.
That's just just living long enough to
see.
That has been marvelous.
That's beautiful.
The last question we ask our interviewees
is, what would you want to say
to future generations if someone were to
look at this interview 100 years from
now, what would you want to tell
somebody who's different?
I thought about that when you first
asked me to do an interview, and
I thought back about the various people
I've met and the things I've done.
And I remember I once went to
a conference, I think, in San Francisco.
And it was in one of the
big conference halls, and I was late,
and I wandered in late, and there
was a guy sitting by the door,
a young man, I don't know, maybe
20 years old.
And he was taking the tickets and
he was serving as the doorman for
the conference.
And when I gave him my identification
and told him what I was, who
I was, he says, oh, you're Larry
Rosen.
And I just felt warm.
So.
So the thing would be that he.
Has.
Develop that kind of service attitude.
Um, awareness of the future.
Awareness of opportunities, whether it be open
source or AI or God knows what.
That I think about that 20 year
old kid sitting at the door taking
tickets.
Uh, saying things about me or thinking
things about me.
I remember when I was at Stanford
doing my teaching, and one of the
people I ended up teaching was a
Nobel laureate.
And I said, oh, you know, look
at me.
I was not quite 18 then, but
still working with a Nobel laureate.
Turns out I asked him a question
about electronics and he couldn't answer it.
So, you know, I realized that it's.
We look at our betters, we look
at our our predecessors, and we stand
on their shoulders, and others stand on
our shoulders, and we do good things
and sometimes we don't.
But my Wish is that that 18
or 20 year old guy that was
taking tickets at the conference.
Well, I said, oh, I met that
guy and he charged me up a
little bit, gave me a ooh, look
who I met kind of thing.
And that he will become the next
hero of his generation.
What else can we want?
Well, that's great, Larry.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for sharing your
story with us.
It's been a pleasure and an honor
to interview you.
Thank you so much for asking questions
and making me think and making me
remember.
Thank you.